you made a big mistake coming
here at Winston but I can help you both
of you if I were to describe night one
in one
word
explosive
homecoming the Continental it really
follows young
Winston and how he became the head of
the Continental we're going to spend
more time trying to dig deeper and
answer some of the questions that the
audience has so we get to know more
about these characters more about these
rules more about this world ah I see
what this is
about in the movies we don't know much
about Winston he's the only one that
calls John Wick Jonathan for us that was
the most compelling character to go o
what if we start there because of
Winston's upbringing there's definitely
a scrappiness to him and a need for
survival he'll always put up a good
fight he just won't necessarily win that
battle Winston gets clocked out of
London into this dark world of New York
in the 1970s it's a really big moment
when him and Frankie meet it's the first
time that the brothers have really
talked as
adults there's a lot of tension there's
a lot of anger and resentment towards
one another and there's also guilt
Winston is aware of how much Frankie
sacrificed for him I think ultimately
for Frankie it was time for him to find
happiness for himself he'd found that
for Winston so it was his turn to find
his own the only way he felt that he
could do that was with this coin press
take Vengeance on tarmac and destroy the
man that had ruined his entire life Mr
Flynn shoot Mr Avery for me but sir the
rules oh yeah the rules yeah H
you got me on a technicality there when
we got a call that Mel Gibson wanted to
do this the 12-year-old boy in me was
like what the guy from Road Warrior I
think what makes an action film work is
if you become involved with the
protagonists you have to hiss the
villains and cheer the good guys or or
the other way around are there any good
guys
give me the pace you really want to do
this my favorite scene in night one is
the intro of Frankie's character
Lawrence one of the coolest things to me
was action is a character red light
active you were able to get the stunt
tape that choreographs all the
movies
cracked to cut my teeth I wanted the
fight scenes Frankie stole something
from
me it holds this entire establishment
together the Continental represents a
threshold once you cross it there's no
turning back Kitty's not somebody that
really follows the rules so when she's
told you stay the out of there the
first thing she's going to do is go in
there there's mystery she's good at
solving things
she's hot on the scent so when she first
goes into the Continental there's an
instinct in her that knows something's
not right but she's not turning back the
part of Yen played by Kate you have to
find a Vietnamese woman who can do
action just blown away by what you can
do she brought weight to the character
in' 70s in Vietnam there's a
slogan when the enemy comes home even
woman fight so that shape my character
[Music]
you thought you could outsmart the high
table how foolish of you Katie McGrath
was fantastic as the adjudicator and
what's great about what she did with
that role was she just had her eyes and
her voice but one tool is taken from her
the adjudicator is very mysterious we
want to know more about the motivations
for that
character you know the music of the 70s
and the soundtrack of the Continental is
is really Albert's Vision what that did
for me was unlock the visual side of
[Music]
it it was inspiring to see that all this
music can work together and New York is
almost the key to that because it's made
up of all cultures we're a family of
color in Chinatown with a
dojo but Lou is the center of her life
she doesn't like guns she doesn't want
to fire guns but she can't get away from
it shoot him shoot him shoot him
relationship with Frankie runs really
deep I mean they they were in war
together you they bullets in those
things right so there's complexity there
lemy is the perfect combination of
action and comedy also I wanted to learn
how to change a magazine in a gun as
quickly as John Wick does it you you see
how fast that is I learned that from
ke so for
Winston there's this connection that he
finally had has why didn't you just
leave when you had the chance you're my
brother Frankie you're all I have
left I think it was important for
Winston to make him vulnerable that he
actually evolved over the course of his
life you also get a sense of that
toughness that we see in Winston in the
movies Winston was in the past is gone
he's now cold and vengeful and he's on a
mission I need
guns
lots of
guns sometimes you got to make choices
you don't want to protect the people you
care
about Frank maybe you'll get to
understand that one
day